temps et valley ça j'ai peu dormi aussi
pourquoi j'avais un gros délire ça ou la
chine alors jusqu'où peut se parler on
n'est pas qu'une mode ya pas mal d'actu
ans on va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
me suis tapé une la honte de ma vie non
hier qu'est ce qui s'est passé est donc
je dis n'est qu'une amie c'est qui je
connais dans un hôtel oui je connais oui
je connais oui c'est ça non mais moi je
dois connaître parce que je il a dit oui
que non ça c'est thierry bezer celle
annoncée pas est ce que c'est une
personne qu'on a déjà vu ensemble oui on
a pris un verre avec elle
non celle d'hier d'accord mais s'il vous
plaît mon côté c'est pas du spic non
c'est parce que tu n'envoies voilà c'est
une personne connue jeudi nice est pas
une croûte jugent non
jeudi avec cette personne pour la
première fois et donc je prends la
confiance c'était dans un hôtel et je
vais voir discrètement le réceptionniste
et je dis ce que je te réserver une
chambre s'il vous plaît manger le dîner
nom est en fait plus dîner avance plus
je me rends compte que je vais pas
conclure ouais et à la fin du dix ans
réceptionniste qui arrive si bon alors
bonne chance monsieur pour ce soir j'ai
réservé sa base à médine avec audrey
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est encore possible non mais on
connaît on connaît pas très bien et
devrait coûter en tout cas vous et vous
êtes vraiment et votre mug regarde
l'émission sûrement votre ex regarde
l'émission en
direct la gestion directe émissions
indirectes on ne coupera rien voilà oui
voilà le cerdi n'est pas beaucoup mais
quelqu'un
je pense que quand vous allez rentrer à
la maison il va avoir des problèmes ça
va vous sinon très bien merci mais vous
dites quoi après l'art maison ou dit
c'est des sardines et confessionnelles
dans la chambre rose éclatant réservé
une chambre professionnelle similaire
merci en tout cas vous avez une drôle de
façon d'être professionnel comme evian
tg matinée un quoi ban aux mains parce
que j'ai pas envie de gens magasinent
ensemble dans les chats cousy vous pas
mieux à la boire
on a fait un jacuzzi en 100 minutes
oui mais non mais où sa belle fille
falette raciale
je suis quelqu'un
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vraiment jacuzzi c'est le
baignoire jacuzzi aspire un petit truc
demain mais oui mais non chaque jour
votre bain avec genton mines ont cédé
chacun son tour non non non non pas de
calais mais pas du tout maintenant
commencer la tradition dernière fois un
échange et élise était tout jaune à pau
ce qu'on fasse un film hélas tard et
après voilà je fais deux heures c'est
peine perdue 0 et je pars l'année où je
venais au mot
rassurez vous je suis toujours été rose
voilà donc la chine où l'on prendrait 20
nuits et j'entendrai prévenu au premier